you
hi everyone it's Jerry I'm chess calm
I'm going to do a few more chess puzzles
three puzzles and like before as soon as
you see the puzzle go ahead and pause
the video if you'd like and see if you
could figure it out on your own so let's
get started
to try this first one where it's black
to play and if you saw the last video I
did with this group of three puzzles
you'll note that you could disable the
timer so I don't have a little thing
ticking away so I'm not exactly sure the
difficulty level as a result of this
problem
but let's give it a go so black to play
hmm my first thought is a check that's
the most forcing move hmm let's see
it might be something to that yeah let's
see Knight check if pon takes Knight
it's a matin to Knight check pawn takes
Queen g5 and whether actually it's
forced knight here
if pawn takes would be Queen check King
here is needed and then Queen g2 will be
mate
so that's one variation however after
Knight check if the King goes here what
do I do next after Knight h3 king h1 hmm
oh well there's there's Bishop takes
pawn that would be a forcing move and
there's also Queen takes rook queen
texture up knight takes that's probably
not it so night h3 king h1 Bishop takes
pawn check King takes would be forced I
think I see it this is all checking
moves Knight check King here Bishop
takes pawn check King must take queen g4
check King has to go back to the corner
my night is on h3 at that point
defending F
- so my queen is here my knight is here
there's no light pun and there's a king
here which would mean that I could do
what was something with this rook
probably just trying to visualize that
position as best I can I believe this is
the first move let's try it again Knight
h3 King here Bishop takes pawn King
takes and Queen g4 check King here Oh
Knight check maybe that's not working
Knight check rook takes rook here
there's a night block mmm I feel like
I'm really close I feel like I'm really
close I'm pretty sure this is the first
move
yeah it's got to be the first move it
seems so right Knight Jack King here
Bishop takes pawn King takes Bishop Oh
is there better
oh no no no Queen g4 King here oh I'm
stuck I can't see it I check King h1 is
there something other than Bishop takes
pawn maybe at that moment like check
King h1 Bishop takes g2 King takes g2
Queen g4 king h1 what could I do there I
can't I can't check on this diagonal
it's not really so great huh hey that's
not it that Bishop takes G to move could
be the case
let's see Knight check King here is
there something else I could be trying
hmmm I wonder if there's like one quiet
move those are it's easy to miss those
like check th one maybe rook here and if
rook takes rook then maybe there's
Bishop takes G to King takes G to Queen
G for I'm stuck I'm not sure I'm gonna
go with this I'm not able to solve this
one through four from beginning to end I
think this is the first move though it
is okay and the King sure enough does go
there the Bishop takes pawn that must be
it right it's gotta be it
it was correct but I'm not seeing it to
its end and now Queen here think yeah
that is correct what am I missing that I
wasn't able to see the winning move from
this position I wasn't able to visualize
this so well this is what I was thinking
at this point Knight check rook takes
rook here but then there's Knight block
what is the what is the move at this
point I've come so far gotta get this
let's see rook here would that be it oh
man that might be it one quiet move rook
here is threatening Queen G one check as
well as Queen G one rook takes rook
takes me as well as simply Knight f2 so
there's two squares these two that need
to be covered a knight can't cover both
the G 1 and F 2 in the Queen can't cover
both of these threats so I think that's
it
I'm gonna go with that I think this is
the quiet move I missed it is and now
yep there it is this is the main ah that
is sneaky all right I didn't see that
one through to its end that was uh that
was tough for me to find that quiet well
I didn't find the quiet move but the
quiet moves are the really the most
difficult ones to see anyhow let's try
the second one okay white to move mm-hmm
let's see first moves I'm considering
well let me do a tally count here piece
count white is down a lot of material so
I'm getting the feeling that there
should be some mate this night I doubt
is going to be able to help forcing
moves Bishop check and rook check it's
probably rook check to start Bishop
check King takes bishop I don't see a
good follow up now I definitely don't
see a good follow up Bishop check King
takes
there's not even a good check next so I
think we're pretty much locked in to
rook h7 yeah let's go there that's it
it's gotta be and now and now what can
we do oh the other thing to consider is
well no I don't think it's gonna be a
perpetual check but being down so much
material may be the best continuation is
to have some perpetual check in fact
that's what we could be having check
King here check check here check here
there is a perpetual check you keep
going back and forth here back and forth
here thank or maybe not it let's try to
win actually I think there should be
some type of a win could be wrong there
is a lot of material down two three four
five six okay
two down two minor pieces there's two
ponds that white has but they're down to
minor pieces so they have a very active
rook you could grab this Bishop hmm and
the other thing is that when you grab
this Bishop you're threatening to just
win this knight on b7 a very awkwardly
placed piece the fiend the fiend cut out
night wonder if Bishop g7 is something
and pawn push these are these are the
two moves and all three moves I guess
rook takes Bishop is a candidate it
seems like it's just a material grab not
really going after the king bishop g6
would really be focused on trying to get
after that King but it's still
struggling here pawn push after pawn
push seems like it could actually be
pretty good because this rook is on
unprotected maybe in some lines like if
this rook could be captured there's like
pawn push huh let's see I think there
might be something in this pawn push
move you know pawn push is threatening
the rook and that's a very serious
threat right you're ready to if you're
there's just some type of passing move
and nothing move you're ready to take
which would be double check and then
rook here and you pick up the rook so
maybe there's a way that white is able
to get back a lot of material that's
probably the case I'm thinking f7 and if
the rook moves somewhere on the e-file
you give check you take this rook and
then you're promoting on the next turn
and that would be a significant amount
of material one so I think this is it
rook pawn here and if rook somewhere
here then then there is what
huh maybe this is a I'm struggling one
of the areas f7 if the rook goes here or
let's say here CA I was I was going to
say here but maybe there's like a way
that the king could run away at some
point so vacate dd8 so after f7 maybe
rook c8 there is this check also I
should have been considering that I
don't think it factors in so much though
so pawn push rook c8 rook check King g7
hmm that's seeing the follow up there
there is also stuff bishop g6
threatening rook check here it seems
like it's just aiming for some perpetual
check I think I have it narrowed down
I initially it was Bishop g7 rook takes
Bishop and f7 as my candidate Mo's but
maybe I'm abandoning this one so I'm
kind of torn between f7 and rook takes
Bishop huh takes bishop isn't so bad
either hmm
I think it's rook takes Bishop I'm not
seeing the f7 rook c8
I think it's rook takes Bishop and then
maybe this night could come in later I
see I don't know the difficulty level
with this problem you there so that
would help actually but uh let's see
Brooke takes bishop and I think I'm
gonna go with that let me look at this
one more time f7 rook c8 hmm I'm not
seeing the follow-up I'm gonna take the
bishop I guess that it doesn't feel
right though definitely doesn't feel
right f7 rook c8 rook check King here am
I missing something
oh oh I am oh I am
f7 rook here rook check if King g7 you
promote to a queen with check rook takes
and then rook here is me no it's not
well it's not the King would have g8 ah
man
f7 rook here rook check King here pawn
promotion rook takes rook check here
there would be king GE I think you're
supposed to grab the bishop I'm wrong
what's the correct dissolution let's see
what the solution is ah there's silly
quiet move whoa slow down oh my goodness
really a quiet move Bishop g6 oh that's
what's the what's the big threat oh the
big threat is made oh my goodness I
wasn't I was I was focused on this f7
square giving check after bishop g6 this
is simply threatening male 1 ah man okay
well that's a lot clearer because how do
you prevent me King g8 oh my goodness f7
you take the rook with double checkmate
Wow
I feel I feel foolish all right let's
see if we could finish on a good note
that was bad let's try this third one
last one okay
okay last problem let's make it a good
one um okay material count is what hmm
two three four five we're dead even with
the material huh how can black win this
one well you're the one thing I know
after pawn takes if Knight takes here
rook to f2 is gonna turn out to be mate
it's not a way to stop mate Queen h2 the
bill gates square right so pawn takes
pawn takes pawn Knight takes rook f2 and
I don't believe there's a way you can
stop made on h2 so and I'm going with
this one well I should be looking at the
checking moves first but they're just
not working this is covered twice if the
night wasn't he
oh my mistake pawn takes Knight takes
rook here check and then me so forget
about this one quiet move f2 if pond
takes Knight takes rook here leads to
mate
so after pawn takes I think this is it
because this Knight has pressure on it
so when you take here the Queen can't go
too far if she goes here you could
always take the night and if Queen takes
Queen you take here a simple little
tactic and then at the end we're out
where else is the Queen going to go if
Queen takes pawn you're taking the
knight if the Queen still goes here to
defend the knight there's this push
exploiting the pin on the third-ranked I
believe this is it
try and dislodge the strong placement of
the Queen pawn takes pawn and go with
that that is correct and there you go I
think this is that's all there was to
this one just the wind of material pick
up the night there's a one check King
here and that's gonna be at rook here
there's always a night block that's it
well that wasn't the greatest puzzle but
at least I guess I got it but I am upset
with myself with that other problem
Bishop g7 one simple quiet move was
threatening a million-one I missed that
how did you do with these feel free to
let me know in the comment section below
and I'll see you in the next video take
care bye
you